we've looked at questions like this
before where you've got this sorted here
here this copy over here where you've
got two quantities that are different
but you're comparing them we call this
rate we see this before but what we had
to deal with these questions and one of
the ones we looked at was a currency
conversion that was very very confusing
and part of it's because it's just icky
to try and get from this quantity which
relates a particular cost to a
particular number kilos to some differ
about now the unitary method is just one
particular approach that might help you
with this it's not required but people
find it very useful it's really all
about thinking about a single unit and
working from there try and draw some
conclusions so as an example here if we
want to work out the cost of five kilos
there's kind of this intermediate
question here that you can answer before
you get to fake healers to help you
understand a king of this which is well
before you get to five just think about
one just think about one unit so in
order to get to there you're gonna take
this Amell and you want to think right
this is a right here so if I say a kilos
- oh no - you're rather bright as a
break because I'm a different different
quantities you measure different things
if I want to work out one can be kilo I
need to divide both sides by 8 this is
just like we saw before because these
rates can be treated just like fractions
you could do everything that you do with
fractions with ratios including dividing
the top which is this first time up and
then bottom which is the second number
I'm dividing both by 8 so when you have
a go of this you can see you're going to
get one kilo over here on the left and
if you reach if you calculate up 1992
that's gonna be divisible by 8 let's
just confirm that and you get a price
per kilo which is what you're used to
actually saying when you're shopping of
course so this is you're after the fact
you've bought
that's your total and this is you know
what it was actually charging you per
kilo so from there you can see having
answered this it's really easy to go to
this photo step here which is well if I
want not one kilo but five I'm going to
multiply this one by five which means
the multiply this one by five okay so
just like with fractions if you're doing
an operation you're doing it to both
part so we see this before under
conversions as well so you're going to
get five kilos here we go that was the
way to get to the spy kilo about that we
were looking for by adding it an extra
step sometimes going a longer path is
easier you didn't have to do that you
can see see how we got two steps you I
could have done them both in one here I
could have divided by a and multiplied
by five simultaneously but it's a little
harder to see that and just adding an
extra step of working it makes it a TV
bit simpler and we have a little
question like this you can still use the
unitary method to approach it it's just
that the unit's you're dealing with are
percentage points so what you're going
to say is in exactly the same way as we
set up before you've got fifteen percent
of a deposit on like a house or
something like that and that's
eighty-four thousand dollars which is
actually not too bad price for a house
so if this is 15 percent what do I got
the total cost what I'm after is a
hundred percent right that's really what
I'm asking so again the intermedia
question is well what's one percent and
then I can get to 100 from there so 15
percent is eighty four thousand dollars
right just like before when you get to a
single unit so I'm going to divide both
of these quantities by 50 that will
leave me with one percent over here per
let's just do the division
and you get this quantity that's your 1%
because you divided everything through
by 15 and just like before I want to go
from that to this next step which I've
identified this hundred percent so I'll
multiply this one by one hundred
multiply this one by one hundred and
then you get a pretty simple calculation
you're gonna add two zeros on to that so
you're getting five hundred and sixty
thousand that's your total cost so just
to review putting the 1% of a one-kilo
or whatever it is put that in as an
extra step not required
you couldn't just do it all in one here
but if looking at the this question at
the beginning and then looking at that
makes it appear I'm not really sure
which star simplify the question first
right and this extra step in and then it
makes it kind of easier as a stepping
stone to get to your final answer